[Music]
where are you going in that top I can do
what I want this is a democracy and if
something happens to you then father of
democracy will come to save you that
father of democracy that Greek fellow
called
cint look it up see I have nothing
against the Greeks they gave us this
great yogurt which is very good for
bowel movement but all this democracy
nonsense for the people of the People by
the people except women and commoners
because they were not people only at
that time you are both even when the
name democracy came out that time it was
democracy and name only so now is not
the time for you to walk out of the
house in that top what about my freedom
of expression it is not your expression
I'm worried about but other people's
expression on your expression freedom of
expression don't throw that in my face
we are the world's largest democracy for
the people of the People by the people
that's cuz we also have the largest
number of people in the world P exactly
so why should the woman on the street
care about your right to agitate your
father and freedom of expression she
cannot dip her chapati in a vti of
democracy and eat oh wow this tastes
like power of the people democracy is
for people who have full stomachs and
Rich
fathers ah are you okay yeah I'm okay
but see papa you can care for more than
one thing at the same time nobody cares
more than us and what has all this
caring gotten us so far in all these
International meetups like these bricks
and tricks and NATO and Plato and all
they ruffle her hair and pincha cheeks
so cute gulugulu who's the world's
largest democracy others build their
Empires using the excuse of democracy
because they make the rules they get to
use them as Weapons they will raise
their economic values while we are the
keeper of their moral values H is this
democracy nonsense that has kept us poor
and then they will finger wag at us to
save water Indians should not wash their
bums think of all the poor billionaires
that don't have artificial snow slopes
to ski down and then they say we give
democracy a bad name how rich of them
which is what they
are even their moral fiber is made from
threads they have stolen from
[Music]
others m
see this is why we need a
[Music]
dictatorship yeah our ancestors must
have really enjoyed being enslaved by
the British which is why we want that
back but now with our homemade tyrants
don't argue with me the only way you
want a dictatorship is if you are the
dictator at least now we have a choice
the illusion of choice well that's what
keeps you hopeful and engaged and what
have you gotten with all this hope and
engagement a democracy and a chance to
have this discussion with you my cutie
pie why are you wanting to put your body
out on the line for a world that does
not want to accommodate your Humanity
because one day it will it's not perfect
and it's not going to happen overnight
but knowing that that day is coming
makes it worth it the world can make a
woman Papa but only in a democracy can a
woman make her own
world live life a little all this
idealism will be
gone remember to take your medicine no
car keys for you you're defending common
man so much no so one day go out and
live as common woman and see what the
world is
[Music]
like
fore
for
[Music]
speech
let
p p did you take your
medicines Papa you know you're supposed
to take them with consistency that's the
only way they're going to be effective
the doctors have told you time and again
that you need to do this because you
don't want to go to hospital again
flirting with the nurses you know how
awkward it gets playing Ludo with
everybody telling people you can cure
cancer with ginger Papa please don't
teach me all this I can do what I want
this is a
democracy
and then who will come to save you
mother of
[Music]
democracy
oh